so getting to risk number two will AI
ruin our society short version as you
write if the murder robots don't get us
the hate speech and misinformation will
and the action you recommend in short
don't let the thought police suppress AI
well what is uh
this risk of the effect of
misinformation a society that's going to
be catalyzed by AI yeah so this is the
social media this is what you just
alluded to it's the activism kind of
thing that's popped up in these
companies in the industry and it's
basically from my perspective it's
basically part two of the war that
played out over social media over the
last 10 years
um because you probably remember social
media 10 years ago was basically who
even wants this who wants who wants a
photo of what your cat had for breakfast
like this stuff is like silly and
trivial and why can't these nerds like
figure out how to invent something like
useful and powerful and then you know
certain things happened in the political
system and then it's sort of the
polarity on that discussion switched all
the way to social media is like the
worst most corrosive most terrible most
awful technology ever invented and then
it leads to you know terrible the wrong
you know politicians and policies and
politics and like and all this stuff and
and that that all got catalyzed into
this very big kind of angry movement
both inside and outside the companies to
kind of bring social media to to heal
and that got focused in particularly on
two topics so-called hate speech and
so-called misinformation
um and that's been to Saga playing out
for the last for the last decade and I
don't even really want to even argue the
pros and cons of the sides just to
observe that that's been like a huge
fight and has had you know big
consequences to how these companies
operate
um basically that same those same sets
of theories that same activist approach
that same energy as being transplanted
straight to Ai and you see that already
happening it's why you know Chad GPT
will answer let's say certain questions
and not others
um it's why it gives you the canned
speech about you know whenever it starts
with as a large language model I cannot
you know basically means that somebody
has reached in there and told it it
can't talk about certain topics
um do you think some of that is good so
it's it's an interesting question
um so a couple of couple observations um
so so one is um the people who find this
the most frustrating are the people who
are worried about the murder robots
right so so and in fact the the X
so-called X risk people right they
started with the term AI safety the term
became AI alignment when the term became
AI alignment is when this switch
happened from where it is going to kill
us all to we're worried about hate
speech and misinformation sure the AIX
risk people have now renamed their thing
uh AI not kill everyone ISM
um which I have to admit is a catchy
term and they are very frustrated by the
fact that the sort of activist driven
hate speech misinformation kind of thing
is taking over which is what's happened
is taking over the AI ethics field has
been taken over by the hate speech
misinformation people
um you know look would I like to live in
a world in which like everybody was nice
to each other all the time and nobody
ever said anything mean and nobody ever
used a bad word and everything was
always accurate and honest like that
sounds great do I want to live in a
world where there's like a centralized
thought police working through the tech
companies to enforce the view of a small
set of Elites that they're going to
determine what the rest of us think and
feel like absolutely not they could be a
middle ground somewhere like Wikipedia
type of moderation there's a moderation
of Wikipedia
that is somehow crowdsourced where you
don't have centralized Elites
uh but it's also not completely just a
free-for-all because uh the if you have
the entirety of human knowledge at your
fingertips you can do a lot of harm like
if you have a good assistant that's
completely uncensored they can help you
build the bomb they can help you
um mess
with people's physical well-being right
if they because that information is out
there on the internet and so they're
presumably there's it would be
you could see the positives in um
censoring some aspects of an AI model
when it's helping you commit literal
violence yeah and there's a section
later section of the essay where I talk
about bad people doing bad things yes
right which which and there's a there's
a set of things that we should discuss
there yeah um what happens in practice
is these line as you alluded to this
already these lines are not easy to draw
and what I've observed in the social
media version of this is the way I
describe it as the slippery slope it's
not a fallacy it's an inevitability the
minute you have this kind of activist
personality that gets in a position to
make these decisions they they take it
straight to Infinity like they they it
it goes into the crazy Zone like almost
immediately and never comes back because
people become drunk with power um right
and they look if you're in the position
to determine what the entire world
thinks and feels and reads and says like
You're Gonna Take It
and you know Elon has you know
ventilated this with the Twitter files
over the last you know three months and
it's just like Crystal Clear like how
bad it got there now yeah reason for
optimism is what uh Elon is doing with
the community notes
um so Community knows is actually a very
interesting thing uh so what Elon is
trying to do with Community notes um is
he's trying to have it where there's
only a community note when people who
have previously disagreed on many topics
agree on this one
yes that's interesting that's what
that's what I'm trying to get at is like
there's there could be Wikipedia like
models a community knows type of models
where allows you to essentially either
provide context or censor in a way
that's not resist the slippery slope
nature now there's another Power there's
an entirely different approach here
which is basically
um we have AIS that are producing
content we can also have AIS that are
consuming content yeah right and so one
of the things that your assistant could
do for you is help you consume all the
content right and basically tell you
when you're getting played so for
example I'm going to want the AI that my
kid uses right to be very you know child
safe and I'm going to want it to filter
for him all kinds of inappropriate stuff
that he shouldn't be saying just because
he's a kid yeah right and you see what
I'm saying is you can Implement that you
could use the architectural you could
say you can solve this on the client
side right solving on the server side
gives you an opportunity to dictate for
the entire world which I think is where
you you take the slippery slope to Hell
there's another architectural approach
which is to solve this on the client
side which is certainly what I would
endorse
it's uh at risk number five will AI lead
uh to bad people doing bad things and I
can just imagine language models used to
do so many bad things but the hope is
there that you can have
uh large language models used to then
defend against it by more people by
smarter people by more effective people
skilled people all that kind of stuff
three-point argument on bad people doing
bad things um so um uh so number one
right you can use the technology
defensively and there's a we should be
using AI to build like broad spectrum
vaccines and antibiotics for like
bioweapons and we should be using it to
like hunt terrorists and catch criminals
and like we should be doing like all
kinds of stuff like that in fact we
should be doing those things even just
to like go get like you know basically
go eliminate risk from like regular
pathogens that aren't like constructed
by an AI so there's there's there's the
whole um uh there's a whole defensive
set of things um second is we have many
laws on the books about the actual bad
things right so it is actually illegal
to be a you know to commit crimes to to
commit terrorist acts to you know build
pathogens with the intent to deploy them
to kill people and so we have those we
don't we actually don't need new laws
for the vast majority of the scenarios
we actually already have the laws in the
book
on the books the third argument is the
minute and this is sort of the
foundational one that gets really tough
but the minute you get into this thing
which which you were kind of getting
into which is like okay but like don't
you need censorship sometimes right and
don't you need restrictions sometimes
it's like okay what is the cost of that
um and in particular in the world of
Open Source right
um and so um is open source AI going to
be allowed or not
um if open source AI is not allowed
um then what is the regime that's going
to be necessary legally and technically
to prevent it from developing
right and here again is where you get
into and people have proposed these
kinds of things you get into I would say
pretty extreme territory pretty fast do
we have a monitor agent on every CPU and
GPU that reports back to the government
what we're doing with our computers
are we seizing GPU clusters that get
Beyond a certain size like and then by
the way how are we doing all that
globally right and like if China is
developing an llm beyond the scale that
we think is allowable are we going to
invade right and you have figures on the
AIX risk side who are advocating and you
know potentially up to nuclear strikes
to prevent you know this kind of thing
and so here you get into this thing and
again you know you could maybe say this
is you know you could even say this is
what good bad or indifferent or whatever
but like here's the the comparison of
the nukes the comparison of nukes is
very dangerous because one is just nukes
for just just about although we can come
back to nuclear power but the other
thing was like with nukes you could
control plutonium right you could track
plutonium and it was like hard to come
by
AI is just math and code right it's and
it's in like math textbooks and it's
like there are YouTube videos to teach
you how to build it and like there's
open source it's already open source you
know there's a 40 billion parameter
model running around already called
Falcon Online that anybody can download
um and so okay you walk down the logic
path that says we need to have guard
rails on this and you find yourself in a
authoritarian totalitarian regime of
thought control and machine control that
would be so brutal that you would have
destroyed the society that you're trying
to protect and so I I just don't see how
that actually works so yeah you have to
understand my brain has gone a full uh
full steam ahead here because I agree
with uh basically everything you're
saying when I'm trying to play devil's
advocate here there because okay you've
highlighted the fact that there is a
slippery slope to human nature the
moment you censor something
you start to censor everything
uh
the alignment starts out sounding nice
but then you start to align to uh the
beliefs of some
select group of people and then it's
just your beliefs the the number the
number of people you're aligning to
smaller and smaller as that group
becomes more and more powerful okay but
that just speaks to the people that
censor are usually the and the
get richer I wonder if it's
possible to do without that for AI the
one way to ask this question
is do you think the base models the the
base the Baseline Foundation model
should be open sourced
like uh what where Mark Zuckerberg is
saying they want to do so I look I mean
I think it's totally appropriate that
companies that are in the business of
producing a product or service should be
able to have a wide range of policies
that they put right now just again I
want a heavily censored model for my
eight-year-old like I actually want that
like like I would pay more money for the
ones more heavily censored than the one
that's not right
um and so like there are certainly
scenarios where companies will make that
decision look an interesting thing you
brought up the or is is this really a
speech issue um one of the things that
the big tech companies are dealing with
is that content generated uh from an llm
is not covered under Section 230 uh
which is the law that uh protects
internet platform companies from being
sued for the user generated content
um and so it it's actually yes and so
there's actually a there's actually a
question I think there's still a
question which is can big can big
American companies actually feel
generative AI at all or is the liability
actually gonna just ultimately convince
them that they can't do it because the
minute the thing says some something bad
and it doesn't even need to be hate
speech it could just be like an enact it
could hallucinate a product you know
detail on a vacuum cleaner you know and
all of a sudden the vacuum cleaner
company sues for misrepresentation and
there's any symmetry there right because
the the LM is going to be producing
billions of answers to questions and it
only needs to get a few wrongs the loss
has to get updated really quick here
yeah and nobody knows what to do with
that right um so anyway like they're
they're a big they're big questions
around how companies operate at all so
we talk about those but then there's
this other question of like okay the
open source so what about open source
and my answer to your question is kind
of like obviously yes the models have
there has to be full open source here
because to live in a world in which that
open source is not allowed is a world of
draconian speech control human control
machine control I mean you know black
helicopters with Jack booted thugs
coming out repelling down and seizing
your GPU like territory well no no I'm
100 serious that's you're saying
slippery slope always leads there no no
no no no that's what's required to
enforce it like how will you enforce a
ban on open
you could add friction to it like harder
to get the models because people will
always be able to get the models but
it'll be more in the shadows right the
leading opens first model right now is
from the UAE like the next time they do
that
what do we do yeah like oh I see you're
like uh the 14 year old in Indonesia
comes out with a breakthrough model you
know we talked about most great software
comes from a small number of people some
kid comes out with some big new
breakthrough in quantization or
something and he has some huge
breakthrough and like what we're gonna
what are we gonna like
invade Indonesia and arrest him it seems
like in terms of size and models and
effectiveness of models the big tech
companies will probably lead the way for
quite a few years and and the question
is of what policies they should use the
the kid the kid in Indonesia should not
be regulated but should Google meta
uh Microsoft open AI be regulated well
so but this goes okay so when does it
become dangerous yeah right is is the
danger that it's quote as powerful as
the current leading commercial model or
is it that it is it is just at some
other arbitrary threshold yeah and then
by the way like look how do we know like
what we know today is that you need like
a lot of money to like drain these
things but there are advances being made
every week on training efficiency and
you know data all kinds of synthetic you
know look I don't even like the
synthetic data thing we're talking about
maybe some kid figures out a way to Auto
generate synthetics that's going to
change everything yeah exactly and so
like sitting here today like the the
Breakthrough just happened right you
made this point like the Breakthrough
just happened so we don't know what the
shape of this technology is going to be
I mean the the big shock the the big
shock here is that you know whatever
number of billions of parameters
basically represents at least a very big
percentage of human thought like who
would have imagined that
and then there's already work underway
there was just this paper that just came
out that basically takes the gpt3 scale
model and compresses it down to run on a
single 32 core CPU
like who would have predicted that yeah
um you know some of these models now you
can run a Raspberry Pi's like today
they're very slow but like you know
maybe they'll be a you know perform you
know like
it's math and here we're back in here
we're back it's math and code it's math
and codes math code and data it's bits
Mark's just like walked away at this
point he was just screw it I don't know
what to do with this you guys created
this whole internet thing yeah yeah I
mean I'm a huge believer in open source
here so my argument is we're gonna have
to see here's my argument my argument
full argument is AI is going to be like
air it's going to be everywhere like
it's just this is just going to be in
Texas it already is it's going to be in
textbooks and kids are going to grow up
knowing how to do this and it's just
going to be a thing it's going to be in
the air and you can't like pull this
back anywhere you can pull back air and
so you just have to figure out how to
live in this world right and then that
and then that's where I think like all
this hand ringing but air risk is
basically complete waste of time because
the the the effort should go into okay
what are what what is the defensive
approach and so if you're worried about
you know AI generated pathogens the
right thing to do is to have a permanent
project warp speed right funded lavishly
let's do it Manhattan let's talk about
let's do a Manhattan project for
biological defense right and let's build
AIS and let's have like broad spectrum
vaccines where like we're insulated from
every pathogen
well the interesting thing is because
it's software
a kid in his basement teenager could
build like a system that defends against
like the worst the the worst I mean and
to me defense is super exciting
it's to like I If you believe in the
good of human nature for that most
people won't do good to be the savior of
humanity is really exciting
yes